الجنائيه للمره الثانيه الاحتفاضه بوثائق
سريه في منزله في فلوريدا في الوقت الذي
يخطط فيه لعودته الى البيت الابيض ليصبح
بذلك اول رئيس سابقا في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده يواجه اتهامات جنائيه محاكمه
ترامب قد تمتدته طويلا ولكن ماذا لو فاز
بالرئاسه التوقعات هنا تختلف البعض يرى
انه من غير المرجح ان تستمر المحاكمه
لاسيما وانهم يعتقدون ان وزاره العدل
تعتبر جزءا من السلطه التنفيذيه فيما
الرؤساءهم اعلى سلطات انفاذ القوانين
الفيدراليه في البلاد وبالتالي يسعى
المدعون الفيدراليون دائما لارضاء الرؤساء
في حين يرى اخرون انه في حال الحكم بادانه
ترامب بعد فوزه بالانتخابات فليس امامه
الا ان يبقى في السجن او يدفع غرامه ماليه
للحصول على حكم بوقف التنفيذ وحينها سيصبح
رئيس امريكي يتعرضوه للادانه من ناحيتها
ترى مجله تيم الامريكيه عدم وجود اجابه
واضحه حتى اللحظه لما سيحدث حاله ادانه
قبل او بعد فوزه بالانتخابات ولا يعرف احد
مصير القضايا المرفوعه ضده لكن من المؤكد
هو ان ترامب رغم المحاكمه يتقدم على
منافسه الجمهوريين في سباق الرئاسي باشواط
وفقا للارقام
[تصفيق]
هذا اضطهاد سياسي مثلما يحدث بشكل صريح من
امه فاشيه او شيوعيه وسوف يسجل هذا اليوم
باعتباره عارا وسيظل جو بايدن في الذاكره
الى الابد باعتباره الرئيس الاكثر فسادا
في تاريخ بلدنا والاهم من ذلك الرئيس الذي
حاول مع عصابه البلطجيه المقربه وغير
الاسوياء والماركسيين تدمير الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوث وتقارير الاخباريه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات